listen I really want to start with a
sincere congrats uh since people are
going to watch this I don't know how
much I can say but I have seen some of
your TV show and I'm giving it a thumbs
up oh great that's great to hear I'm
glad I'm glad to hear that um so I have
a ton of questions um but one of the
things I want to talk about and and I
want to commend is Apple TV and I know
that sounds crazy but the Sci-Fi that
they're making is arguably the best on
any streamer right now between For All
Mankind so the things on Apple like
Foundation Silo uh For All Mankind and
now your show like I'm really Blown Away
by the the quality so talk a little bit
about what is over there that's making
all these show so good I mean a bunch of
smart people um who are excited about
telling different stories and about
being ambitious um they're great
collaborators they're passionate about
what they're doing and for a show like
this to take a big swing to travel
internationally we shot in Tokyo we shot
in Vancouver Canada we shot in Hawaii we
moved all over the place um just to get
the scope and scale to tell the story
right so I think that's the biggest part
is that they're telling interesting
stories and they're doing them right
they're approaching them with the the
scale that you need to be able to to
pull them off effectively well one of
the things I'm going to say and this is
a jokey thing but it's true I was
impressed by how many extras you had in
this show and that is like a little
detail that a lot of people aren't going
to realize that like a lot of extras
cost money and that's like movie scale
is having extras a lot of TV shows have
like four people in the room because
that's what you can afford and I think
that's one of the things that adds a lot
to Apple shows it's true and I think
post coid too you know while we were
filming in coid we had to limit our
numbers so I think a lot of the things
we've gotten used to seeing on
television had reduced background for
that reason because we were trying to
keep things safe and so we limited the
amount of people there and uh for a show
like this this being able to see 200
people you know running down the street
screaming about Godzilla um that's
definitely was something on my bucket
list I was very happy to check that off
and to be able to have the resources to
do that right is pretty awesome so one
of the things is uh how much did you
guys in the development process figure
out exactly what takes place with
Monarch and the characters between where
it all starts and like 2015 you know
like how much is that all filled in in
case you get to do more Chris Black Matt
fraction I have to give them all the
credit because they developed the show
they created this version of the show
and they worked hand inand with
legendary because there's a a lot of
Mythology to wrap our heads around and
so they very carefully constructed a
show that could work within the existing
mythology of the films we've seen and
the films we're going to see um and to
be able to tell a story in multiple
timelines requires being really
thoughtful about how all those things
will intersect the show is about Legacy
you know we we begin with a a big
gesture towards um some of the things
you've seen before I don't want to ruin
or spoil anything um but everything sort
of comes from that moment and it's about
many generations grappling with a world
with monsters both the good things and
the bad things um and so you know just
carefully working within the existing
mythology and expanding it wherever we
could well with a show like this which
um I'm just curious when you when you're
every when everyone's working on this
how much is Apple saying um what's like
a three season plan or how much is it
just like okay well what's this season
going to be because you know obviously
they're looking for for shows that are
going to last I don't think they want to
make a show that only goes one season
Maybe I'm Wrong um so like how much are
you guys exactly so how much are you in
the in when you're putting when you're
figuring all this out figuring out okay
well we'll go till this point then
season two could be about this and it's
not like it's getting written but at
least you have an idea it's when you
pitch a show from the beginning you
pitch what's the story of the first
episode what's the story of the first
season and what's the story for the next
five years you know that's pretty much
expected when you go to pitch a company
like apple on on the show that you want
to create um of course things change
right you have all these plans and then
you realize that this is a more
interesting Avenue and things evolve and
you do that hand inand with the studio
and with you know with apple and with
legendary to kind of develop and follow
where the story wants to take you and I
think I've found from storytelling that
if you rigidly adhere to a plan that you
have the audience sees it coming like in
ways you need to take all of the
surprises and push them forward and keep
surprising yourself as a Storyteller
because you need to be able to you know
dig yourself a whole you can't get out
of and then figure out a great way out
of it because then the audience enjoys
that too um so that you know that's how
it works it's both planned but also it
evolves and then when you bring people
in you know when the when Chris and Matt
the creators of the show were first
developing it they didn't know that Kurt
Russell and Wyatt Russell would be in it
and they didn't know how they would
function and then when that element came
in which is extraordinary
it took that character Lee Shaw and
turned it into something different and
moved the story in a different direction
so you know you want to you want to ride
the good wave and uh and develop the
best show you can yeah um well first of
all uh getting Kurt and his son to or
why to um uh to play these characters is
genius because it's it's just so good uh
was it always the how did that come
about actually and was it ever going to
be two different actors you know what I
mean certainly we discuss two different
actors you know I think that's the usual
approach to things um but we had this
idea that Kurt Russell and Wyatt Russell
who are often I think offered things as
father and son you know but I don't
think they'd ever been offered the same
part to play in two different time
periods and it just felt like what an
amazing idea and it's so rare I mean two
actors who are extraordinary on their
own uh two actors who bear an uncanny
resemblance to each other um because
their father son uh playing the same
part just felt like an idea that we had
to to run wholeheartedly at and they
were excited to do it um and I think you
know also it's such a unique fit because
Kurt Russell stars and all the movies I
love and and since I was a kid I've been
watching him on screen and the idea of
Kurt Russell plus Godzilla just feels
absolutely 100% right um he he occupies
the same awesome space um and so and
then the the fact that Wyatt you know
could could work so beautifully um as
the young version of that same character
just it just was Serendipity you know
things that we couldn't have have
planned you know the fates made possible
for us when you get Kurt which is an
amazing amazing casting does it all of a
sudden change any of the scripts where
people are like we need him to have a
little bit more screen time or was it
sort of like he's just going to fill in
what we have no there's definitely an
evolution for sure I mean those parts
were already important the it's a it's a
rich tapestry and I don't want to ruin
too much for people but we're telling a
multigenerational story as as I
mentioned about Legacy and so it was
already a really beautiful chessboard
and all of these pieces come together in
surprising ways these characters
interact and intersect in different ways
and so that character was a hugely
important figure but obviously you want
like I was saying earlier you want to
ride the w if you want to say okay well
we didn't imagine that it was Kurt
Russell when it was first written now
it's Kurt Russell which is amazing how
does this character you know because
great actors and great characters kind
of merge and they find a place in the
Middle where you're pulling all the the
things that make that person awesome uh
as a performer and you try to move them
together and it's fun because I think
Wyatt is a great actor but he's a
different kind of actor than his dad and
they they have a different approach they
come from different sort of schools of
acting in a way but they enjoyed
creating this character together they
enjoyed building the character together
and trying to kind of meet in the middle
so Kurt's like well I do a certain kind
of thing but Wyatt does a certain kind
of thing can I do Wyatt's thing and and
why it's like well can I be my dad for
like can I be snake piskin like how do I
get there like and in a way they kind of
met in the middle and built Something
Beautiful which was a fun thing and I
think a great thing for them as Father
and Son as a project to kind of come
together and do was really special was
it always going to be 10 episodes or did
you guys debate doing eight and then
having more money because you would have
less episodes the plan I think was
always 10 you know I think that that
felt like the number that that felt
right for the story um we we never
considered a different number and that
was what Apple was looking for too and
that's how the story got developed so
one of the things about this is like
everything you're going to have a budget
I don't know what the number is but
let's call it $10 let's say you got $10
to make this show we already know visual
effects are going to take money and big
visual effects are going to take real
money so my question is how much did you
guys in the writing process say okay
we're going to be able to afford four
major action set pieces in season one
where do we want to put them you know
like how does that get figured out
because you do only have so much for you
know those big set pieces I mean it's an
ongoing thing because as you develop
stories and when you're developing
stories that happen to intersect with
giant Titans it's going to create set
pieces along the way but yeah you have
to always keep that budget hat in mind I
mean in Game of Thrones uh which a show
I worked on it was always like you know
what's the sort of beginning middle and
end set piece that's going to carry us
through this SE season and we know we're
going to put a lot of resources towards
that and then you start negotiating down
from there you know per episode um and
obviously in the Pilot We want to we we
want to pull out you know all of our our
our biggest sort of moments to kind of
hook you into the world and so the pilot
has some bigger moments beginning middle
and end in the same way that the season
has beginning middle and end and then
you start to figure out where you need
like the midpoint of the Season needs
its big moment and and it's all just
something you have to navigate because
you never have enough money I think I
enjoyed watching a documentary about the
making of a Harry Potter movie and the
set designer was saying oh we ran out of
money for Dumbledore's office so I
reconfigured three other sets and made
this thing you're like they ran out of
money on Harry Potter they run out of
money on everything um so at some point
you have to be clever and sometimes the
best ideas come from being clever when
you're you're back into a moment you're
like I don't have the money to do that
thing you figure out obviously Jaws
being the great you know the shark
doesn't work you know we don't see the
shark you see buoys instead being pulled
along and that's even better for the
movie so great discoveries come from
limitations are you allowed to use other
hoo monsters how much do you guys have
to create your own monsters besides like
Godzilla um for this series one of the
great things about this was the chance
that to create new Titans new monsters
to add to the monster verse so that's a
part of it using um folks that we know
and love from before is a part of it and
I don't want to say too much you know so
that you can be excited about what you
see when you watch it sure uh I'm won
pressure you um so I'm reading this
because someone put this on Twitter I
asked her questions on Twitter thought
this was a good one uh will during the
series will any details from the comics
be changed or will they be Faithfully
following the events of the comics such
as Godzilla Awakening and Godzilla
Aftershock like do the comics factor in
one of the creators is Matt fraction
who's a brilliant comic book writer and
is is well-versed in that world I'm a
comic fan too but I would have to say
that my my knowledge of the Godzilla
Comics is not as deep as his or some
others and many of the people I'm sure
who are on Twitter asking that question
uh I think we were more concerned about
building and working within the
mythology that's been established by
legendary you know and so where it has
diverged from Comics um we have probably
diverged as well but you know we were
very careful about mythology there's a
whole department at legendary that
handles this and that looks very
carefully at that and I respect that a
lot because I think when you're building
a universe you need consistency you need
authenticity you need your world to feel
lived in I think that's the thing I love
most about movies and and when you're
World building you need it to feel lived
in and uh and they help you do that so
the show jumps around in time um which I
really dug actually I thought it anyway
I I don't want to say too much um my
question is if you get to do another
season do you guys think that it will
follow a similar trajectory of jumping
around in time or is it something you
haven't even thought about yet
definitely have thought about it don't
want to say too much but you know the
the the notion of of of legacy and
generations dealing with things is part
of what the show's DNA is so I think you
can sort of imagine that what might
happen there uh one of the things though
is you have a lot of different people
involved in the making of this series
you have too you have apple you have
legendary then you have the filmmakers
and the there's a lot of people that are
cooking this meal how tough was it to
find a story that everyone said oh yeah
that's good people were very excited
what Chris and Matt cooked up uh was
exciting for everybody it brought me in
I was incredibly excited about the story
felt fresh I think everybody realized
that when you're telling a a series when
you're doing a drama series over 10
episodes you need to be fully invested
in these characters on the ground and so
their approach was really about telling
a monster story from the point of view
of the people on the ground which is
something that I love doing on Game of
Thrones too like I'm far more interested
in what's happening you know in the
Lannister Army on the ground being
burned up uh you know and how war is
changing it's the same way of you know
trying to to understand what it's like
to be
the people in San Francisco as the
monsters go by and sometimes the movies
which are incredible are focusing
they're at a higher altitude you know
they're dealing with Kong versus
Godzilla and so we needed to make
characters that would pull you through
that story that you would love and care
and be concerned about um and then also
deliver the excitement of what the you
know what's happening in the upper
atmosphere too but more from the
perspective of the people on the ground
they cracked that beautifully they had a
very fresh we in I think everybody was
excited about that from from the get-go
people at Apple people at Tojo people at
legendary and they're all incredible
Partners you know too is doing
incredible Godzilla stuff themselves and
they have you know uh something coming
out very soon and they you know they've
been doing just incredible incredible
work and they are great partners and it
was fun to go we shot it you we shot all
over the world as I said but we were in
Tokyo shooting and to go to too Studios
and they have a big giant bronze
Godzilla statue out in front and to
realize that this is where kurosa was
shot this is where all these things that
I've Loved were made it felt it was a
exciting Place full of ghosts of of my
childhood you know it's great I got to
visit too on not the last Godzilla one
of the films I forget which one but I
got to watch the new movie in too's
theater they pulled out all these old
props I lost my mind because as you said
it's where kurasa made movie like I was
losing my mind it's crazy they still
have old in a way that our Studios can
feel um as as as traditional a way you
walk around and you see the mold making
shops The Prop Shop the creature shops
like everything it feels like those
movies that are set on um you know
Studio Lots where you're walking around
and everybody's dressed in as Romans and
Crossing through like too still feels
like that in a way that our studio Lots
don't quite feel that way anymore it's
it's awesome yeah it's a really fun
place how many of the 10 scripts did you
guys have done before filming began and
how much were you thinking about in
terms of cost savings filming certain
sequences together because of I'm not
sure if you could you know like having
you get what I mean like block shooting
whatever you could how how did that work
we shot two episodes at a time chunks
you know I did the first two and you do
get uh you get an economy for from doing
that you get uh the opportunity to be
clever about how you use sets and and
how you uh Focus your time you spend
your time and your money and your
resources on some big things and then
you're able to move more quickly through
some smaller things um so we did that
it's impossible to block shoot or even
shoot chunks of the entire 10 episode
season I think that would have been uh
too difficult given all the complexities
of it um uh but they had I mean they had
many many scripts written before we
started there were a few that were still
in outline form as we were starting to
shoot that got written throughout the
beginning part of shooting uh and things
are always fluid like as you say like
there's budget stuff we need to be
clever or we you know location doesn't
work so we try to figure out a new place
and Recon us at piece you know it's a
fluid
thing